what did women really go through can I
just ask you that this okay what do you
mean what do we go through what do you
what do you mean what what have we gone
through I don't know it's a question you
said women
are oppressed no no no oh okay so that's
just that that's just straight off a
completely different opinion yeah and if
you think they are you would have to
explain how they are yeah what do you
mean explain how women are oppressed
how how do you think they're not no no
you're answering a question with a
question because I history history like
if you go back to
bad diet
my nan if I go back to that far she
didn't have her own bank account to her
assemblies till she till 1970s so she
was 60 and how all of this start in
terms of voting work Child Care order
that I don't understand how you can step
back and say no women have got it all
right